Hello?
Hi. We are gonna be playing some Carried Away today. Which is a game that's been often requested. Hello
everybody welcome out there. If you guys remember a game called Poly Bridge this game might be kind of like that one
I'm not a hundred percent sure. And I probably should go through the tutorial shouldn't I?
You know what just in case. I'm gonna do that okay? Ok go. Hello?
Oh, do I actually have to select it tha-that prolly, probably important, okay.
So this game where you're trying to make a ski-lift
And if you don't make it right, people die(wow thats nice), I'm assuming. 'Welcome to the Rookie Mountains
My name is Jimmy, and I'm gonna teach you the lost art of chairlift construction.
Let's get going! My last apprentice built this chairlift, but he's uh, he's no longer with us.'
I think that means he's dead very, extremely, dead
We're gonna need some wheels to support the rope. 'Select the wheel material and place it on top of the existing tower'
Okay, all right. 'Great! Now grab the orange rope'
Handle and drag it to the other side of the chairlift station. Okay, time to test this beauty. All right.
(a very impressed Markiplier)
3d. Hey don't worry, you're not gonna die probably you know horrible monsters accident. Oh, no it was wonderful
Oh, yeah, f*ck oh my god wait. No. There's no cliff!
There's no cliff. It just goes off into nothingness goes into a frozen lake where they just die
I'll go for syndicator all right sure that's good force. Okay
Next what a relief you've already made it further than my last apprentice now
the question remains did that Prentice is he no longer with us because
Like he died in an accident
Or you killed him, Jimmy (he defiantly killed him)
because
If I'm not mistaken
Maybe you're sure wasn't read the first time you wore that if you know what I mean it select the plank building materials to cheapest
And weakest material
For chairlift construction I couldn't agree more
I literally cannot agree any more than I already am agreeing with you, buddy. God, you are the smartest handsomest, dude
I've ever seen in my life. Oh, that's handy dandy Randy football, okay
Don't forget about wheels and ropes sure whatever long bling lamp no
That's ring around the rosey the wrong way all right there. We go test that bad boy mmm ah
That's good, shit. Oh. No. I don't like the color is
All right, it's good. It's cool. It's cool. All right. Let's see level tree. No that means, but okay this tower doesn't look right
I wonder why? All right let's repair it right-click on the node to drag it to a new location
okey-dokey then
Okey-dokey then alright. Yep. This is safe. Okay, uh?
We're going do blade. Oh, we're gonna build a weight that doesn't look right Jimmy. You're leading me astray here
You asshole (LANGUAGE) all right, Jimmy else we got here. I got hungry and ate the blueprints Jimmy
I'm thinking you got hungry and ate your last apprentice (same)
I don't know what you're talking about over here, Jimmy, so you're gonna have to build this one on your own all right
Okay
Use the spacebar to switch between builder and simulation modes if you don't succeed the first time
You can select the towers using the tower selection tool alrighty
Then you know what I'm gonna build this old mono e mono style which is uh?
I'm a grandpappy used to do it back in the old days there get like a box structure going on here
Everybody needs to trust me I was I used to be an engineer maybe in a past life. All right. Yep
No, that's not quite right. Yeah. I wait there. We go. Nope. Yeah, yeah
Yeah, okay move this down football-sized all right cool. Yeah, everybody happy with this no
Can't imagine why what are you talking about proper construction and the such as like as that. (weird noises) all right hope nobody died
What what's the worst that could happen people die a horrible death and then everything, but everybody's dead yee
That's a lot of force. You know if you could stop bouncing on the ski lift
That would be a greatly appreciated if you could do that
Did I do it?
Did I dunzo it
Did every boy what kind of kind of stupid-ass ski lift is there good to go over here, and then oh, okay?
It's a teleporting ski lift. Okay. All right. It's some kind of magical okay, then ski school
Yeah, sure we'd have to teach people out of ski too cuz I'm not about that. Oh, hi
Who the hell are you, I like your red hair  hey, I'm Carrie. I've taught just about everyone here around here out of ski
It's not easy but with my help
You'll conquer the slopes and no wait why do I have to ski?
no one told me that I was gonna have to ski here everyone told me that I was just gonna build ski lifts and I
Thought that was the extent of it because my engineering degree doesn't cover skiing last time. I went skiing I fell down and broke my face (ow)
With my help
You'll conquer the slopes in no time skier has encountered an obstacle on the way down crouch down load of improved and up tall
You know these words don't help me jump to early jump to late you're gonna. Have a bad time
Okay, all right cool. All righty, then let's get some speed going here
What did blood shoot out of my ankles wait a minute huh am I okay? (no)
Are my knees supposed to bend that way
Me sir, all right fine. Let's try this again. Not this not with the camera good well going in blind here. We go oh
Hey
Apparently we call that a success around these bars
How do I get a follow cam on this son of a bitch Jimmy Starr?
I don't want to go on Jimmy Starr, Jimmy likes shiny stars. Why are you talking about yourself in the third person?
Jimmy Jimmy okay, they're scattered across the mountain sometimes you must collect them and deliver them to the top to pass a level, okay
I'm right there with you. Jimmy. All right sure what is this view objectives now. I don't need to worry about that funk
Funk 'old all right thwamp
I like to get a nice incline going on my tower got to get it higher
Higher going one direction than it was originally going the other way just to get some get some extra oomph in there
Everybody likes their ski towers with extra oomph. I've heard this on the radio
Sometimes that's good enough all right slap some wheels on that bad boy.
Bob's your uncle we got a star going didn't need both of those, but you know I'm just gonna send them for a loop-de-loop
Just give them a couple of like a watt getting their money's worth at least you know
See let's see what happens here. I bet we're gonna get the star though. Hey you have a good
We seem to have encountered our first troubling issue here well there goes oh
They survived all right. Let's try that and no no one died no one died yet
But we're gonna hang this everybody just hold on to your horses, we obviously don't need this
I remember I delete things but I know how to undo so let's just pretend like this entire travesty was
Never dreamt up by such a such a mind as me
Not quite that high, but this I that's how high we need it
Oh, yeah, that's the good stuff counterweights or something something like that. No, no look good enough to me
I don't need that much wood. Well. You know
overkill is my name
Overkill is what I do. You know what actually you're it's totally right. I only need the one of these don't I huh?
Again, I don't know how to delete so I guess this is gonna be here. How do I care?
Remember out it nope that was undo that you there. We go okay selection ah
Get out of here. No we can't get out here get out of here
Okay, all right, okay, and then wibbly-wobbly whoo
That's what I'm gonna. Do got it everybody come on. I can't calm down looks about right. Yeah, okay?
Yeah, it looks pretty pretty okay. Hey, they're not dead so what who'd have thunk
There's a lot of pressure on that a little bit wait. Maybe cuz the wheel ain't exactly
Maybe that wheel don't seem exactly right there getting a little counter offset to uh what I was supposed to be doing over here
But it's alright. It's okay, Jimmy Starr is a raging success all right here. We go
We got a we got a ski now. I don't know why is so funny, Jimmy we need to build a jump why?
Why you can build jumps just about anywhere how?
Why Jimmy Jimmy you're you're not making no sense Jimmy Jimmy. I don't I don't understand what you are talking about ah
Jimmy all right whatever man all right you see jump
Move and zoom the camera to focus on the building ah I'll do a blindfolded just as good right. Yeah, I agree
Okay, all right zoom zoom zoom
That's a nice. Oh, it's a sweet zoom you know
I think we need a bigger angle on that the angle of that dangle. Just just don't feel right there we go
I know what I'm - okay fine. Whatever
For you. Oh, I see what?
Here oh
Oh you idiot. I would knew that was gonna happen sure okay, all right. All right sure all right
Whatever we got it lean forward lean back
All right, Carrie here. We go all right go buddy crouch lean. I don't know which way we're supposed to lean oh oh
Clearly pressing backwards. Oh we got another one oh oh
We don't even need to do nothin to believe the level without killing any riders well that doesn't seem right at all
Oh, what are you even doing? Why is this advanced maybe because it doesn't go anywhere, maybe because this particular ski lift
Just kind of goes off into nothingness all right sure whatever you know what I'm not gonna question what you're talking about
I'm just gonna go for it. All right. There's more to cheerless and just playing some wheels what?
No, don't lie to me like this don't make me feel so small the rope and logs can be useful
They have different properties - planks logs are stronger longer heavier
And more expensive than planks okay, whatever once you get let's put a long strong whoa?
I don't like the way that grow oh
Yeah, it's fine like this no, that's even more penile like but something about how the logs there, and it's slightly like veiny looking
it's just throwing me off a little bit. I don't know why I can't explain it. It's a weird
I don't know. Maybe I'm weird probably all right. Well. We got log
Got a whole lot of log going on all right like it ropes and logs and such
cool
Sure, all right. All righty. Then whap whap well. I don't need to do that, but I'm doing it anyway
But hold onto your horses
I like how that one rope is just completely slack something tells me Jimmy might let me
Let me down the wrong path here if I was a skier
I don't know if I'd be too trusting what's going on here mark stop describing the logs, please yeah
I'm gonna describe them even harder (no)
I'm gonna describe their length and their (please no)
Aptitude in their their shaft like nature just in terms of vivid detail the likes of which you'll never get out (stop)
Mind em I know man Oh
God that was just that segment I feel like I've been playing for 10 years
Oh, no that's not even the second
And I did that's just "the warning" okay "the warning" all right good great, and and that's yeah
This is all welp that didn't work. That's all you need, slap it on there
Hurry up. I know I'm gonna win go
(pure shock)
Cool, so what do I do about them? Oh? There's the problem child over there? Well okay? I think
That'll do it. That'll do it. All right. What if we?
Let's do it like this. Yeah, that's that looks more that looks stable. Let's try that
Yeah here it is I
Built the ultimate
skier murder, (no mark)
There he goes his brains got gobbled up in there real good like okay alright, then anyway
So I'm gonna just clear all that I don't have logs. I can't log this up
I only got planks thin- planks. That's all I got so you know what?
Yeah, we're gonna, try it up like this all this style and such we're gonna give it one of the old these treatments
It's gonna be an expensive one, but you know at least it's gonna be safe
And that's what that's what I that's what I prioritize your markilpier HQs. We go the safety, so safe
Everybody hop on the safety mobile here. We go go a little faster there
At least try something tells me I'm I'm making it a bit too heavy
I seem to have completely ignored all the lessons taught to me from the tutorial there we go
This is the one, wow. There's the one oh, you know. There's the one easy peasy up
Like it's nothing who'd have thought that I was- oh they hit the ground a little bit there, but you know oh
god no, the horror...
Know the warning might have been might have been an indicative of
About what was just gonna was success
Hey know. What? Dead? Oh? Well that one may be dead don't think the knees are supposed to go that way
But because you hit that sign you should you pay attention to the sign? It's clearly there for your protection
Death by warning. Yeah. I like that. That's it seems great within the specified budget. Yep
You know me I always reach a budget when it comes to safety standards all right. Yeah, give it to me there
We go okay. I'm done. That's good luck for that one. Oh, I still see the outline of his corpse over there by that lock